[Music]
i continued traveling north america
meeting mras from all walks of life
hearing their personal stories their red
pill moments
i met a young man who was sexually
abused when he was 16 years old while
living at a residential home for people
with developmental disabilities she's
the only woman i've done anything ever
with apart because it just messed me up
so much
she continues working there
[Music]
she hit me in the face
she actually hit me throughout the house
chasing me throughout the house
when i reported my domestic assault to
the police officers i did not at all
bring up the fact that i was sexually
assaulted because if he wasn't going to
believe that i was a victim of domestic
violence
there was no way he was going to believe
that i was going to be a victim of
sexual assault
[Music]
i met the honey badgers
women who are men's rights advocates
[Music]
and then there was a 15 year old boy
there's a 35 year old woman and then
later on she came out of jail and she
was able to collect child support
from this boy that she raped
yeah
after getting out of jail so there's
there's lack of fairness for men in brah
you hear that
35 year old woman 15 year old kid she
got child support off of him
and she did it yeah
she did it
what the
what the
and that kid oh
oh
yo
what
what
you
what you have no you have no rights
after you do that to somebody and you go
to jail for and you come out you better
figure it out
you better bruh she should be in in jail
forever you better figure the freak out
cause
no
and you
how how is the system that
i knew was bad but how is it that bad
they don't see men as human
that's
that is crazy
to
grape somebody
go to jail for it
get pregnant by the person you grape
and then come out of
prison
and have to pay
pay the person
that grape you pay child support
what
oh my goodness no the court systems when
police officers were show up to domestic
violence case there was often men were
just taken away without asking what even
happened it's just presumed that men are
the criminals
i was assaulted several times you know
and and i never got any help i went to
the police still bleeding a couple of
times
and one police officer
said
uh i'll never forget this he said if she
starts hitting you again you better get
out of there fast because if she just
breaks a fingernail trying to hit you
we'll arrest you
i mean i can't tell you at this point
how many guys i've talked to who are
like
yeah you know she stabbed me and they
put me in jail
not only are there endless studies that
show women are just as violent as men
are when i would talk about it
invariably men would start coming out of
the woodwork with stories
beyonce snubbed cigs on me poured
boiling water on my lap and held a steam
iron on my arm i never hit bro hit these
hoes hid these hoes
that was [ __ ] up you can hit her but
then it's like they don't want to
because they could go to jail if they
even like hit like you know even in
self-defense that's that's the crazy
thing all this stuff has happened to
this man and if he lays a finger on that
woman
he gets charged and it's like women know
women know that women know the double
standards to where if they can do x y z
to a man if he lays a finger they know
that he will go to jail before they ever
step foot in that jail that is
sick that is sick it's sick
that the that women
are manipulative like that and it's sick
that the system is like that
it's stories they were afraid to tell
stories attacks with knives pelted with
heavy objects and alone with their abuse
their shocking is reality for male
victims of domestication
for
stories that they got blamed for
it's
it's
wait don't she threw a dumbbell at his
face
i would
i would chuck i would drop it drop it
right on the head
smash it from the top down
no
what
nah
this is not flattering to men to talk
about men's vulnerabilities no to talk
about the ways that they are not strong
and that they
they are well weak
um and to be honest about it's not
flattering
a solution for both genders
is that we need to be able to recognize
how men
are vulnerable and we need to be able to
recognize how women are actors
because we have a huge blind spot
especially when women do bad things
[Music]
my best friend that i grew up with since
kindergarten was being physically abused
by his wife who had been married to for
20 years
she'll break glass and throw it out and
punch him i've seen it just happened
spontaneously and
it was frequent
and he's bigger than her but he didn't
want to hit her
and he didn't want the children they had
three minor children he didn't want them
seeing this at all
so he would usually just go outside
because they would be glass breaking or
things being smashed or yelling and he
knew that the neighbors might think it's
him
so he would go outside so the neighbors
can see what's happening
eventually i said look you're gonna need
you need professional help and so does
she and maybe the kids do too
so i
called a bunch of domestic violence
shelters i i just looked around online
and i called but every place that i
called said we don't help men we don't
help male men at all
and
i started becoming curious about why
that was because i learned that these
were state-funded shelters
and i know that men pay at least half of
the taxes that fund these shelters if
they're state funded and i just was
wondering why
so that's so interesting like it's again
men are paying
for women but they don't return the
favor
exactly
basically there was no place to take him
and it just continued the problem just
kept going
[Music]
in the united states there are over 2
000 domestic violence shelters
all of them serve female victims
and nearly all of them
turn away male victims
in fact as of 2016
there's only a single domestic violence
shelter for men
my initial reaction what'd you say i was
just saying
in arkansas like that's
that's crazy oh
was that there needed to be thousands
more women's shelters because that many
more women are being battered
but as it turns out
one in three women
and one in four men
will be victims of physical violence by
an intimate partner in their lifetime
sure there's a slight majority of female
victims
but how can that excuse denying men help
couldn't this be considered gender
discrimination
[Music]
think of it this way
roughly 78 percent of all suicides are
men
if suicide prevention services only
served men
wouldn't we see the gender
discrimination immediately
[Music]
if there are over 2 000 women shelters
that turn away men
and only one shelter for men
obviously the resources don't match the
need
how are you involved in the men's rights
movement
well from the very beginning when i
first opened the refuge which was in
1971
in chiswick in london
uh almost as soon as i took the women in
i got a house for men
a voice for men's editor-at-large aaron
pizzi
founded the first ever women's shelter
in 1971
and she is widely revered in the men's
rights community
because you see what i knew from the
beginning most domestic violence is
consensual both are involved
sometimes one's the perpetrator the
other plays the thing listen to this
part this
i was so shocked about
you hear her and then it crosses over
it's not it's not as though it's just
all men or all women it's both
an occasion the innocent victims very
innocent
[Music]
battered children grow up to better
that's what i learnt
whether it be a man or a woman and i now
know that if a woman comes in with a
history of violence in her own childhood
the chances are she will be probably
violent to her children and she will
want to live on this knife edge of
crisis and danger
i haven't been allowed to speak that's
the difficulty why is that because i'm
completely barred from all conferences
like i'm not allowed to walk up the step
of my own refuge i bought the bloody
building but no because there's
feminists the woman who runs it is a
very happy family she won't have
anything to do with me
what did you say that made them hate you
that women could be equal what i said
i'd take away that building so quick i
better listen here
that's your chick
you wouldn't have a job if it wasn't for
me get up out of here no i think it's
state funded so like she bought the
building with the state takes it over
the state ruins everything
i think that's what i am gathering but i
don't know
just men that was from the beginning
[Music]
aaron pizzi says that 62 of the first
100 women to enter her refuge were just
as violent as the men they left and
violent towards their children
so that's the thing they act like women
like
i know half y'all hoes are crazy that
are in these abusive relationships like
i'm sorry
y'all are hitting back stop acting like
you're victims
boo freaking if you're hitting him back
it doesn't count
you're equally toxic you deserve each
other
you should just go beat each other up
for life
but leave the kids out of it give them
give your kids to someone else